she was admitted to hospital and rapidly
went downhill
once admitted on oxygen
um then various progressively
more severe stages ventilators
and eventually um it was becoming sort
of a life-threatening situation
for her and her unborn baby
imagine being told to prepare for the
worst
a doctor tells you that your pregnant
partner and the unborn baby inside her
are unlikely to survive that's what
tommy larkins was told
he was terrifying most terrifying
thing i've been through in my life it
was awful
um to potentially lose the pair of them
on the same night was was really bad
really bad
elsa became critically ill with covert
19
just after christmas
[Music]
heavily pregnant she was rushed to
kingston hospital
her health deteriorated quickly and she
was moved to one of the hospital's two
intensive care units
here she was put into a coma and
intubated
elsa spent two weeks in intensive care
on this ward and with a desperately sick
mother there are always concerns
about the unborn child elsa was one of
the unit's youngest patients
at just 34 she had no underlying health
conditions
but she was carrying a baby
being told potentially to say your last
goodbyes
to you to your other half and to your
baby
as well he's you know your world comes
crashing down
is that possible how long you are sick
for
two weeks from today difficult
conversations
are happening all the time okay have you
got any beds yet
no not yet alison's just gone to the
office to sort it out
a relentless flood of sick patients
needing expert care okay
so the answer is please don't let them
take any staff from you without going
through me yeah
because i've been fighting it never
stops
i've been here for about half an hour
every time i've seen you you're on the
phone
people are coming up to you it's so busy
we're double the normal capacity
and the patients are a lot sicker than
we normally see staff shortages
our staff are sick or they're shielded
because their families are shielding as
well
so that makes it more difficult for us
this must put a lot of pressure on you
and your team
all the time it's constant yeah
everybody very constant and things like
that you don't imagine you don't even
think about then the number of medicines
we need we don't have enough cupboard
space
we don't have enough space for the
equipment to store it
uh we're having to swap ventilators
around because we've obviously had to
get new ventilators in
yeah take we'll take this to his arm
for the staff here on the front line the
pressure
is constant it is taking
its toll
how long seriously do you think you
carry on at this point
um i think we're on our knees we're all
being very trying to be very positive
i have staff who phone up in tears they
can't come into the building so we have
to send another nurse out to go and pick
them up
i think once they're here it's not so
bad it's the thought
of how am i gonna cope looking after
that many patients
and uh and support staff you're right
can you hear me
all right it's one of the doctors here
you're at kingston hospital
right you're just waking up and coming
around you're doing really really well
can you give my hand a squeeze just let
me know you can hear me
squeeze hard excellent well done we
don't need to worry about anything to do
with it until it bleeps
the pressure is being felt right through
the hospital
this is one of its high dependency wards
very sick coveted patients who need help
to breathe
are sent here
beds are at a premium i just wanted to
let you guys know
we've got our environmental um
and it's difficult to predict demand
i worked the weekend and it was a nice
steady weekend we were looking after the
patients that are coming off the back of
the christmas and new year peak
and it was nice and calm we never used
the quiet word in the nhs
and then today we've had an awful lot of
admission straight through a
e unusually for this surge that have
needed
ventilation either invasive or
non-invasive i've got to be honest it's
been really really hard like any
hospital in london
but we are we are making capacity all of
our staff have worked extra shifts to to
man up
the the additional care needs that these
patients need rini
has been on this unit for one week her
battle with kovid
she tells me took her to hell and she's
not sure
she's back how are you feeling a lot
better i
thought i was dead i've
never i've never had
pain like that in my life and there is
nurses to get me through
and doctors i cannot believe what they
did to me
when i was 76 i've got cpd
and i still got through
they're marvelous people there's always
worse stuff than they do
people coming every day and you're
seeing me think
that i was like you
thought you know i still trust this
design i'm thinking
your family must be very worried about
it absolutely i've got a lot of family
very terrified my daughter was asked to
come up the hospital
to say goodbye to me with my son
because i might be dying
did they come and see you
tommy had the same devastating
conversation
with his family he broke the news
to his girls melissa and alba
it's a potential that mummy's on a knife
edge
well i'm pretty sure she i'm sure she's
going to be okay she's a fighter
she will be home but just to let them
know
uh make them aware because they're a bit
older
so make them aware that where we all
need to hope on january the 5th the
decision was taken to deliver elsa and
tommy's baby
by emergency c-section a full two months
before the baby was due the operation
could
save elsa's life but it carried
a huge risk absolutely petrified
you know the baby it was during march
the the second week of march you know
to be to have an emergency c-section
uh a baby potentially born with covid
um uh he
it was it was awful awful you know
the baby's going to come out whether
she's going to make it or not she's
going to have to
put herself on a ventilator and
breathing
apparatus it was all very dark it was
all
quite quite a horrible place to be
one of the critical care nurses who
cared for elsa
thankfully there's not we haven't seen
many uh pregnant ladies
but elsa was particularly sick when she
came in um
she was really struggling to breathe i
think the difficulty with that was the
fact that she was
heavily pregnant um the big bump that
she had due to the pregnancy was
obviously pushing on the bottom of her
lungs
so as kovit had infected her lungs she
was finding it
difficult to breathe anyway and then
with the added pressure of baby
squeezing on the bottom of her
lungs is making it even more difficult
for her to breathe so she did require
quite a lot of support all the time that
she was here elsa's condition
worried gags not just because she was
his patient
but also because he is expecting a baby
too
if i'm honest it was it was really
really frightening
because my wife is actually 36 weeks
pregnant
uh so a few weeks further on than elsa
is and um
she's also a nurse i'm an intense care
nurse and when she came in i saw how and
where elsa was
if i'm completely honest i was really
really quite frightened lovely
and any other problem you
might be concerned about when beds
are in such high demand capacity must be
managed
and usually he's quite independent he
lived with the curious package of care
but
he treated otherwise mobility wise
hospital
and local gps working together to find
answers
to the crisis actually typically
patients who look at to
discharge back into primary care some of
them are off oxygen some are still on
oxygen but as long as they're
continuing to be weaned off then there
are support services in the community to
be able to pick them up
things like sending people home on
oxygen is really something we've looked
at in the second wave because bed
occupancy has been so much higher
so we're looking at trying to get you
home with some support services okay so
we just need to ask you a few questions
to make sure that you're suitable before
you came into hospital otherwise you're
well and you didn't walk with a stick or
a frame
but at the moment you're needing some
assistance to to get around
well not really because my husband will
be there okay so he'll be full time
there with me
okay the family must have been very
worried about they were
they were worried you know i come from a
big family
and all the time i was getting emails
saying you know
hurry up pull through pull through but
my husband always said i had a stubborn
streak
i think you know when you've been here
long enough and you need to get back to
your family
yeah and you're ready for that now i'm
ready for that
already
for uncertain patients the familiarity
of a gp
brings extra reassurance
i think if you see an awful lot of
patients that got covered
they're in an unfamiliar surrounding
they've got oxygen
they've had loads of medications they're
on drips they're scared
okay so a lot of patients are scared and
so to be able to reassure them that
there are people who are going to know
them
in the community to be able to pick them
up penelope will
soon go home but for some patients the
waiting goes on
tommy's partner elsa is not in intensive
care anymore
but she is still covered positive hello
mr bray and this
is their new baby a little girl
elsa and tommy's daughter weighs just
1.4
kilograms and needed life support
in those first few critical weeks day by
day
hour by hour that
she again she had ups and downs
so she only needed a small
ventilator tube and a nose to begin with
then a day or so later a full ventilator
was put on and she's tiny she's still
tiny
basically a ventilator the same size as
her body attached to her
uh and seeing that like that
[ __ ] it's heartbreaking heartbreaking
tommy has been allowed to visit his
daughter and partner
on compassionate grounds after seeing
her so weak and poorly
in an incubator um to to holding a
a couple of days ago it was amazing
amazing
best feeling to come through and see
that lightly under the tunnel
um it was was amazing
and we've still got a little way to go
still not out of woods
um the the effects um
could could stay with with both of them
or
maybe else or more uh for a long while
yet
um so hopefully we we keep keep pushing
forward
and she keeps fighting elsa has yet to
meet
her beautiful tiny fragile daughter
it could be weeks before all three are
home together
the pandemic baby who survived against
all odds has a name
hello she's called florence
a tribute to the nurses and doctors
who saved her and her mother's life
ashish joshi sky news
at kingston hospital